[Musique]
et bonjour justin pamphile
bonjour oui du président de
l'association des maires de la
martinique mère du lorrain et conseiller
territorial siégeant à l'assemblée de la
ctm justin pamphile parlons de
l'actualité dans la caraïbe de ce qui se
passe chez nos voisins de saint vincent
et de cet élan de solidarité qui vient
de la martinique
hier vous étiez en séance plénière
première journée et donc justement la
ctm a déjà envoyé 5000 400 litres d'eau
1 puis sur le stock de la collectivité
territoriale vers saint vincent
tout cela a été acheminé hier soir une
cellule de coordination technique
c'était un préfecture a été mise en
place vous avez décidé aussi de la mise
en place d'une commission de
coordination au sein de l'assemblée de
martinique en lien avec le conseil
exécutif
et puis et puis l'association des maires
dont vous êtes le président depuis l'an
dernier
il va aussi de son élan de solidarité
vous avez fait une adresse à vos
collègues et dillenseger saint pamphile
en fait nous avons reçu une demande de
la l'association urgence caraïbes au
travers dont de madame marie luce qui
nous a demandé de faire le relais donc
auprès des des collectivités l'intérêt
c'est que les mairies ont l'habitude
quand il y à des demandes de ce type
d'art organisé et à collecter des
denrées sur l'ensemble du territoire
dont au moins tout le territoire et
irriguer les demandes sont des bidons de
5 litres d'eau des pelles des paillettes
du matériel de première nécessité si en
plus de cela aussi de manière à ce qu'on
puisse venir en aide à des personnes qui
ce cas effectivement en situation un peu
critique donc donc vous demander aux
municipalités de mettre à disposition
des points de collecte c'est cela c'est
ça ça vaut dans les rues ou dans les
services et pour ça on sait faire les
mairies s'affairent
c'est un point identifié et qui
permettrait effectivement aux personnes
qui le souhaitent de faire un geste
souvent ce sont également des denrées
des denrées on va dire sèche au des
conserves de manière à ce que le
l'acheminement puisse se faire une fois
que tout sera collectée et un lien avec
urgence caraïbes que ça soit diffusée
sur
le samazan entendu alors en tant que
président de l'association des maires
retour pendant quelques minutes pas trop
long parce que c'est un peu complexe et
on sur ce dossier du trop perçu par
rapport du trop perçu de la part de
certaines municipalités par rapport à
une anticipation de baisse des recettes
d'octroi de mer une diminution de
notation en quelque sorte
alors certaines municipalités ont puisé
un petit peu dans dans cette enveloppe
on va dire et puis il faut que qu'elle
rembourse certain nombre de
municipalités doivent rembourser dont
celle du lorrain je crois oui bien sûr
alors vous avez trouvé un accord en
négociant discutant avec eux la
préfecture pour que cela n'obère pas
trop les budgets municipaux et qui a un
étalement
enfin la sphère paraît un peu alambiquée
non il presque insolite france
maintenant il y accompagne maintenant je
voudrais simplement dire les choses
y'a pas de y'a pas d'alambic apad l'état
simplement avait mis en place un
dispositif qui permettait de compenser
des dotations dans la perspective d'une
réduction importante des des sommes une
régulièrement mensuellement versé au
collectif tout ça c'est dit à la crise
que les rédactrices du coc vis
exactement n'a pas baissé pas que
l'octroi de mer puisqu'il n'y a pas que
l'octroi de mer comme taxi à l'octroi de
mer il ya la taxe d'habitation et c'est
donc en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que on s'est rendu compte que le ce que
l'on n'attendait était supérieur à ce
que l'on craignait et les montants
qu'ils ont été versés à différentes
collectivités simplement ce que si on
vous avez si vous percevez un trop perçu
mais ce qui vous est demandé simplement
c'est de le rembourser et ce que nous
avions nous vu avec l'état c'est de dire
que ont fait le constat que la somme
effectivement il ya un trop perçu au
lieu d'avoir un prélèvement unique ce
que certaines collectivités ont fait de
fait elles ont versé les sommes la somme
qu'elle avait trop perçu directement ne
peuvent pas et d'autres ne pouvant pas
nous avons demandé qu'il y ait un
échelonnement par 12e tous les mois donc
il ya un prélèvement qui est fait sur la
dotation mensuelle de manière à ce que
la situation puce retournée à la normale
l'inconvénient c'est que il ya des
collectivités qui sont effectivement
difficultés parce que vous avez deux
aspects vous avez l'aspect très haut
et donc les liquidités budgétaire et
puis vous avez l'aspect comptable
l'aspect envahie aux documents
comptables et là effectivement ça peut
poser pour certaines collectivités une
grande difficulté donc mais social pour
elle aujourd'hui c'est à la fois de
rétablir en fait les écritures
comptables et puis ensuite derrière
faire en sorte que ça ne va pas
préjudice sur leurs documents comptables
et de manière beaucoup plus globale
encore quelques mots donc là vous avez
négocié en tant que président de
l'association des maires vous avez pris
votre bâton de pèlerin mais là vous
dites attention si certaines
municipalités sont pas tout à fait
satisfaite voudrait encore revoir les
les choses
à charge pour eux d'écrire maintenant
directement aux préfets oui c'est à dire
que si ce qui est obtenu et qui me
semble être un élément de retour à une
situation on va dire normal vous avez un
trop perçu vous l'avez rembourser vous
le rembourser par 12e maintenant si
certaines collectivités estiment que ce
n'est pas ça n'est pas suffisant
moi j'oublie comptablement les
collectivités fonctionne par exercice
comptable et la voir rentrer dans un
procès ce qui est un peu plus complexe
moi je reste persuadé aujourd'hui avec
l'expérience que j'ai il vaut mieux sur
l'année budgétaire 2020 t1 sur le dé
cette opération il est passé à autre
chose
en 2022 voilà souvent c'est des
centaines de milliers d'euros à peu près
par exemple ne pas citer la ville du
lorrain aujourd'hui nous avons eu
versement de leurs 281 7000 euros
quand on a fait le calcul ça nous fait
un prélèvement de 20 mille euros sur les
7 8 mois qui restent donc pour nous
c'est difficile mais c'est pas notre
argent il faut le rembourser c'est tout
c'est aussi simple que ça donc même si
vous leur dites au maire qui sera encore
insatisfait d'écrire directement elle
vous servez en corne intermédiaire bien
sûr toujours vous saisir toujours bien
évidemment puisque j'ai dit au préfet
ben dans le courrier que nous lui avons
adressées c'est que nous réglons la
dimension trésorerie nous réglons la
problématique du 12e et puis si
maintenant il y a des difficultés à
venir sur les collectivités notamment
pour ce qui concerne le compte
administratif en particulier mais il
faut qu'on se revoie pour ne pas
pénaliser pénaliser ces collectivités là
justin pamphile donc président de
l'association des maires de martinique
mère du lorrain et conseiller
territorial aussi à l'assemblée
justement l'une des dernières séances
plénières est en train de se dérouler à
la commencé hier nous avons fait
allusion en début d'entretien elle va se
poursuivre encore aujourd'hui l'une des
dernières séances avant le scrutin de
renouvellement de la ctn les maires
auraient été consultés y compris des
maires de martinique que finalement
report des dates ou pas bon il y avait à
ceux qui ont répondu 50 50 une partie
souhaitait que ça puisse être reportée
pourquoi pas compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire
et puis d'autres étaient favorables au
maintien au mois de juin finalement on
s'oriente vers des dates 20 et 27 juin
ça devrait être tout ça devrait
entériner entre aujourd'hui et demain
avec le parlement français entre le
gouvernement et le parlement français
vous c'était quoi votre position et
celle de maintien n'était viable de
faire en sorte que l'élection puisse se
tenir
parfois vous savez on n'a pas beaucoup
de débats sur les sur les ondes sur les
réseaux sociaux
moi la seule chose que je peux dire
c'est que le 15 décembre 2015 nous
savions tous qu'il y avait des élections
dans six ans et que la crise sanitaire
est venu effectivement perturbé on va
dire l'ordonnancement normal des choses
je crois à deux mois d'une élection on
l'a déjà repoussé une fois c'était mars
nous sommes en juin nous sommes à deux
mois je pense qu'il faut faire cette
élection renouveler les instances
démocratique martiniquaise et et faire
en sorte que la vie continue et que la
vie reprenne
on ne peut pas baisser le rideau parce
qu'il y avait effectivement une crise la
seule chose que nous savons pour avoir
essuyé les plâtres notamment depuis sur
l'organisation des élections municipales
nous savons ce qu'il faut faire nous
savons comment il faut faire
il faut simplement faire en sorte que
les gestes barrières soient respectés la
distanciation que toutes les mesures
soient prises pour que les gens puissent
voter en toute sérénité et en toute
sécurité sanitaire et puis que la ctm
continue de travailler les martiniquais
ont besoin de ça donc par conséquent on
ne peut pas s'arrêter de fonctionner
parce qu'il ya effectivement une
situation sanitaire qui nous préoccupe
mais la vie la vie doit continuer alors
fort probablement scrutin le
renouvellement de la ctm 20 et 27 juin
le bilan de la mandature la première de
la ctm métier je reprends un terme que
vous avez utilisé à l'instant il a fallu
essuyer les plâtres et avec au passage
quand même comme une sorte de
dissensions entre conseil exécutif et a
semblé alors quel est votre regard de
ces cinq ans si on analyse la réalité
les cinq années qui viennent de
s'écouler il y a eu de temps il ya eu
plusieurs temps il ya eu le temps de
l'euphorie de la victoire de ceux qui
ont gagné
ça n'a pas été facile au début de la
mandature il y a eu ensuite le temps
plusieurs temps de le temps des
interrogations des atermoiements voire
même des des suspicions dans la majorité
elle-même
et puis il ya eu le temps on va dire que
là entre guillemets de la division
identique également dans le camp de
l'opposition quand vous regardez bien
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une position
unitaire moi même j'ai un peu pris mes
distances par rapport à cette opposition
là et je vote en mon âme et conscience
quand il faut voter des sujets
importants pour la martinique
par conséquent on va dire que c'est à
dire c'est la vie qui c'est qui se
déroule à la ctm aujourd'hui on arrive à
on en arrive à la renouvellement chacun
et s'est positionné chacun a pris des
positionnements que l'on soit dans la
majorité dans l'opposition ou
éventuellement sur des cieux des soins
quand qui n'est pas un camp qui était
clairement identifié moi je crois que
nous sommes à deux mois c'est tout à
fait normal ce qui se passe là chacun
repris cbi chacun repris ces barques et
puis chacun ira à la bataille en juin et
les choses vont se rétablir à juillet et
sur le fond sur les actions sur est-ce
que cinq ans après finalement écouté il
suffit de regarder avec qui peut aux
manettes de la ctm mouassa a décrite que
je vais juger boulot c'est pas l'équipe
que je vais juger je vais juger le
travail qui a été fait je prendrai un
exemple c'est celui de la route de
sainte marie l'awt de fonds saint
jacques
nous sommes sinistrés entre guillemets
nous sommes sinistrés en novembre et
aujourd'hui la route est ouverte moi je
crois qu'il ya des choses symboliques et
les martiniquais en particulier ceux qui
sont dans le nord de l'île comprennent
ce que je veux dire
parce que pendant cinq mois à faire là
la déviation par reculer a été complet a
été difficile
je crois que ce ce set cette réalisation
efficace pour moi et mes marques
le parmi les opérations que l'on peut
identifier une bonne opération en plus
pour le reste vous savez il ya toujours
dans dans une gestion ce qui peut être
qualifié de très bon et puis ce qui peut
être qualifié de moins bons pour le
reste ce que les gens doivent retenir ce
que j'en retiens moi c'est d'abord ce
qui est efficace ce qui fonctionne parce
que c'est ce que nous devons garder en
mémoire pour le reste vous savez dans
une gestion il ya toujours des moments
difficiles donc entre cette appréciation
de globalement plutôt positif vos
attitudes d'électron libre
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure on
peut dire ça le mot le mot électron
libre et le lait c'est peut être un peu
pour être mal interprétés je vote en
fonction de ce qui est bon pour mon
territoire pour mon pays et c'est pas
être électron libre quand on fait ça on
est pas je ne suis pas au vent je suis
simplement dans un vote qui est bon pour
le pays j'ai voté le budget est et en
disant clairement que à deux mois des
élèves sujet 2029 jamais les 21 je les
voter en disant qu à deux mois des
élections
les entreprises ont besoin d'avoir les
moyens les associations aient besoin
d'avant la moyenne aux mondes économique
a besoin dans certains disent que c'est
le signe avant coureur d'un
positionnement déjà pour les prochaines
élections et que vous pourriez vous
retrouver sur une liste de manière un
peu surprenante par exemple avec une
partie de l'équipe sortante la de la
majorité sortante
moi je suis à mardi vous être approché
par exemple d'alfred marie jeanne je
suis maintenant de chercher un exécutif
je suis un martiniquais je travaille
avec tous les martiniquais donc quand il
faut voter des sujets pour la martinique
je les votes et quel que soit celui ou
celle qui le présenterai et qui c'est un
bon projet un bon sujet pour la
martinique
mais il a déjà est ce que vous seriez
candidats à retourner à la c'est
évidemment puisque je pense que le
travail que l'on fait à la ctm est un
travail qui est à la fois un travail de
proximité pour d'abord faire en sorte
que dans un territoire le nord en
particulier le lorrain de manière
beaucoup plus précise
et puis la martinique mais si on estime
que le travail que l'on fait n'est pas
un mauvais travail mon jeu je n'ai pas
de difficulté à me repositionner
maintenant est ce que je me suis
rapproché ces faits déjà très clair mais
je pense qu'avec un certain nombre
d'autres camarades d'autres amis nous
aurons dans les temps prochains à dire
exactement
le choix que nous avons fait les
martiniquais le connaîtront ils semblent
déjà quelque peu se dessine et même
certainement même ceux qui ont peut-être
qu'une bonne lecture de la vie politique
martiniquaise
moi ce que je sais je travaille pour mon
pays et pour le reste chacun en fonction
de ses de ses orientations politiques
choisi ce qui est meilleur pour le pays
martinique
merci justin pamphile vraiment a répondu
à nos questions à à bientôt bonne
journée à toutes et à tous merci
beaucoup bonne journée à tous